the PewDiePie channel is dying I need an
item an item so full of meme that it
will bring back this channel to life but
what item contains such power that can
only be one bacon
so for this week's five word stuff
online I've got a special guest with me
here the bacon man himself Harley
Morenstein
thank you yes he has a tattoo that no
one else has seen before we had every
single bacon product on the market if
it's hot and savory so we're gonna try
and eat I mean I'm gonna try a Harley
it's just gonna give them to me Harley
give me the first bacon item please
bacon Thank You Harley Morenstein I
really appreciate you doing a
collaborate with me taking the thumbs up
like Harley always - bacon lollipop but
does it taste like bacon corn syrup
water artificial bacon flavor I'm not
gonna eat that fine I'll give it a try
would you like to try it Harley bake it
excellent okay
it's good and give this zero bacon out
of zero it doesn't not taste like bacon
tastes like lollipop next item please
big thanks Harley bacon bandages how did
you know they're my favorite oh look
it's bacon hilarious Thank You Harley I
will transcend this earth this Swedish
blood will become bacon not in the beer
please Thank You Harley thanks now I can
become one with my people but does it
taste like bacon oh my god
this is like bacon but ten times better
next item my Harrison thank you
Oh bacon mints that's hilarious it even
got a little little pig on it
bacon mints
little girl I reminds me of having bacon
except it's not really bacon thank you
next item thank you but I'm not eating
this no [ __ ] you bacon soap they really
thought of it all didn't they don't buy
it so cuz it'll get stuck in your teeth
Oh next item please big gift from the
gods
bacon flavor toothpicks if your bacon
soap gets stuck in your teeth in between
the in-between I have never been so sick
of bacon in my entire life I'm pretty
sure I will never have bacon again thank
you Oh Harley that's generous no no no
no no holy [ __ ] you Oh a gift from the
gods
bacon toothpaste didn't even charge it
this is bliss this is just we're on it
that's oh gosh stuck everywhere and you
know when you go to the dentist and you
have to date the mold it was exactly
like that the flavor I can live with you
know you know whenever I glanced at
myself in the video it's just a reminder
what the [ __ ] I'm doing
these items are also funny and hilarious
but we need to summon bacon new you sir
all right another month another
lootcrate this is February's box that
we're gonna unbox it's the theme is dead
next one is gonna be vs. let's check out
what's so dead about oh my god look at
that that's pretty cool oh my god yes
more Deadpool ooh
I met Ryan Reynolds you know we hung out
he didn't know who I was but he doesn't
matter it's really cool but they printed
it upside down so I don't know man we
got a big lootcrate exclusive Deadpool
fig Q you got exclusive stopping you
sign up to loot crate that's cool I'm
gonna keep this on my desk right next to
my baby but wait there's more a pen it's
the walking dead so I wonder what it
tastes like
and finally the walking dead characters
will we get Rick or will we get Darren
obviously I want Darryl because he's the
only one in the show that doesn't act
like a little [ __ ] it's Rick damn it
so that was February's loot crate
remember to check out the website loot
raid calm such periods into the code
period so you get 10% off you know the
deal
haven't you sign up yet you don't want a
cool Deadpool figure I bet you do you're
a [ __ ] you get 10% off support your
show thank you
the next item Harley Morenstein oh I'm
actually down for this this one I will
very happily eat so it's sizzling bacon
candy you know the sting that pop so
you'll pop on your tongue just like
bacon pops on your I'm so tired of
[ __ ] bacon do you hear that
I mean it's just working so miserable
right now this is supposed to be a good
item but it tastes like [ __ ] I hate
bacon they oh another one
a bacon air freshener hilarious next
item well you really think there
wouldn't be any more you can [ __ ]
pull out of your [ __ ] with a bacon
gimmicks thank you
Oh bacon gum boss they look like little
bunny bacon poop these are not bad I'm
not gonna like one hardly bacon bacon
bacon
surely there's no more bacon baby
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] you god damn it I told
you that I was trying to Amy so that the
horrible bit didn't hit you and it did
I mean bacon bacon frosting for your
bacon hmm let's see what it tastes like
just air
oh I think somebody wash it down Dave
McRae what the [ __ ] is this bro what it
was a body wash Oh Harley thank you
you're an epic troll name
leave a like if you enjoyed watching
this video remember to check out loot
crate calm slash pewds add the code
boots and get 10% off and as always as
we do it Harley they bacon [ __ ] fist